Привіт зараз ви почуєте дещо шокують
принаймні для мене це виглядало Саме так
бо за першу половину 2022 року
українська влада дала можливість Росії
заробити кілька мільярдів доларів після
початку повномасштабного вторгнення Як
саме
Зараз будуть докази
у квітні президент Зеленський після
зустрічі з президентом Європейської ради
шарле мішелем заявив наступне ми
Закликаємо ЄС до повного енергетичного
ембарго щодо нафти і газу нафта точно
має увійти до 6 санкційного пакета без
цього він не буде потужним а буде
порожнім в кінець цитати
але в той самий час Україна сама сприяла
постачанню російської нафти до
східноєвропейських країн ЄС Угорщини та
Словаччини тощо
ось документ який я отримав у відповідь
на свій запит до митної служби в ньому
чітко йдеться про кількість нафти і газу
та аміаку які пройшли трубопроводими
України після прямого вторгнення Росії
отже
розсміфть та Лукойл прокачали понад 5
мільйонів тон нафти Газпром понад 10
мільярдів кубометрів газу ну вочевидь
саме кубометрів бо в документі помилка
газ не міряють в тоннах якщо взяти за
основу Лондонській бержові котировки то
за півроку
увага за півроку українська влада
дозволила прокачати українськими
трубопроводами російських товарів на
суму понад чотири мільярди доларів 4
мільярди доларів
ці гроші отримала Росія завдяки транзиту
через Україну
що таке 4 мільярди доларів Ну для
порівняння це майже половина всього
річного бюджету на забезпечення збройних
сил України у 2022 році тобто розумієте
що сталося так
ви можете сказати що можливо це було ще
до Великої війни
але ось інформація в українському форксі
лише у серпні державна компанія
Укртранснафта повідомила що транзит
російської нафти припинено ні не через
те що ми годуємо окупанти через те що
Росія банально не заплатила за транзит
незбиральних міркувань а суто з
матеріальних у серпні після півроку
ширкомасштабної війни
до речі запізнили припинення транзиту
саме напередодні холодів радше грає на
руку Росії якби українська влада
повідомила партнерів навесні про
неможливість постачання російським
енергоносіїв через Україну внаслідок
відомої всім причини європейських країн
неактивніше шукали би заміну російським
енергоносіям Тим більше що Україна не
єдиний ексклюзивний транзитер і газу і
нафти з Росії вони надходять в
Європейський союз з іншими
трубопроводами можете подивитися зараз
на карту
може скажете що контрактні обов'язки
України здійснювати транзит мали бути
виконані Ну окей тоді раджу звернутися
до списку форс-мажорів які містяться в
контракті і до яких входять бойові дії
цей пункт угоди мав би дати владі поле
для маневру але політичної волі вочевидь
не було
припинили російський транзит лише тоді
коли Росія припинила за нього платити
Ну і насамкінець компанії Лукойл та
рознефть під санкціями США Розетці і під
санкціями Європейського Союзу їхнє майно
заарештовують в Америці Німеччині інших
країнах А українська влада допомагає
заробляти цим компаніям мільярди
але на цьому не все я подав до
Міністерства фінансів запит як саме
Росія оплачувала Україні транзит її
товарів вартістю щонайменше 4 млрд
доларів
Мінфін перекинув запит на митну службу
митна служба поки мовчить а там може
бути багато цікавого
продовжимо цю розмову а зараз висновки
робіть самі